THEY DON’T DO WELL.
RICHARD, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: AFTER JOE BIDEN,
THE OTHER BIG LOSER ON TUESDAY
WAS ANOTHER EX-FRONTRUNNER,
ELIZABETH WARREN.
SHE FINISHED FOURTH.
SHE DIDN’T REALLY HAVE THE VOTES
OF THE THIRD-PLACE FURNITURE,
AMY KLOBUCHAR.
IF YOU HAVE BARELY HALF THE
VOTES OF AMY KLOBUCHAR -- NO
OFFENSE TO AMY KLOBUCHAR -- NOT
GOOD.
OFFICIALLY, ELIZABETH WARREN’S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IS STILL
GOING, NO ONE BELIEVES REALLY IT
MEANS ANYTHING.
IN FACT, WE CAN’T SAY AT THIS
POINT WHAT EXACTLY
ELIZABETH WARREN IS RUNNING FOR.
MAYBE SHE HOPES TO GET A FEW
DELICATES SHE CAN EXCHANGE FOR A
CABINET JOB IF A DEMOCRAT WINS.
MAYBE SHE WANTS TO SABOTAGE
BERNIE SANDERS BECAUSE HE IS A
SEXIST BY SIPHONING VOTES FROM
HIM.
MAYBE SHE JUST LIKES TRAVELING
AROUND GIVING SPEECHES AND LOTS
OF SERMONS, FLYING AROUND
PRIVATE PLANES, WHICH SHE LOVES
TO DO.
BUT ONE THING FOR CERTAIN,
WARREN IS NOT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT BECAUSE SHE THINKS SHE
CAN BECOME PRESIDENT BECAUSE SHE
CAN’T.
DESPITE THAT, AND HER
NONCONCESSION SPEECH LAST
NIGHT -- THIS IS VERY TELLING --
WARREN BRAGGED ABOUT TAKING HALF
THE BANK ACCOUNT OF A BROKE
COLLEGE STUDENT TO FINANCE OR
DOOMED AMBITIONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS YOUNG WOMAN CAME UP BY
HERSELF AND SHE SAID, I AM A
BROKE COLLEGE STUDENT WITH A LOT
OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
ANGIE SAID, I CHECKED AND I HAVE
$6 IN THE BANK.
SO I JUST GAVE $3 TO KEEP YOU IN
THIS FIGHT.
THAT’S WHAT WE GOT TO DO.
WE GOT TO STAY IN THIS FIGHT
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE COUNTING ON
US.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
SHE’S LITERALLY BEGGING MONEY
FROM THE INDIGENT TO CONTINUE A
CAMPAIGN THAT CAN’T WIN.
IT’S NOT EVEN A CAMPAIGN AT THAT
POINT.
IT’S A RELIGIOUS MOVEMENT OR A
CULT.
REALLY, I DIDN’T EVEN HAPPEN.
WHO KNOWS.
WARREN HAS BEEN CAUGHT LYING
ABOUT SO MANY THINGS WE CAN
ACTUALLY CHECK.
JUST IMAGINE WHAT SHE SAYS WHEN
SHE CAN’T BE CAUGHT.
I MEAN, REALLY.
IT’S TAMPING TO SAY THAT WARREN
COLLAPSE, THAT HER CAMPAIGN DIED
BECAUSE ELI THOUGHT THAT
THAT IS ACTUALLY NOT THE CASE.
WARREN HAS BEEN LYING FOR A LONG
TIME.
SHE PRETENDED TO BE AN AMERICAN
INDIAN.
REMEMBER, THAT HAPPEN BEFORE SHE
LOCKED HER CAMPAIGN.
VOTERS KNEW IT AND YET FOR A
WHILE SHE WAS THE DEMOCRATIC
FRONTRUNNER.
SO CLEARLY DEMOCRATS WERE
WILLING TO FORGIVE HER
FABRICATION.
NO.
SHE JUST STARTED CAMPAIGNING FOR
MUCH MORE INTERESTING REASONS.
WARREN FELL APART FOR THE SAME
REASON BETO O‘ROURKE DID.
IN PLACE OF A METHOD, AN ACTUAL
MESSAGE THAT UNITES PEOPLE
AROUND IDEAS AND POLICIES, SHE
WENT ALL IN ON WOKENESS.
ALL IN.
EVERY PUBLIC APPEARANCE BROUGHT
OUT A NEW FACET TO HER
REMARKABLE WOKENES.
HER TOWN HALL ENDORSING
RATE-BASED REPARATIONS.
>> I BELIEVE IT IS TIME TO START
THE NATIONAL, FULL-BLOWN
CONVERSATION ABOUT REPARATIONS.
>> Tucker: SO SHE WROTE THAT
FOR A WHILE.
THEN BY SUMMER, THAT WASN’T
ENOUGH.
REPARATIONS, OLD HAT.
WARREN IS NOTHING IF NOT
CREATED.
SHE INVENTED A BRAND-NEW, KIND
OF RACISM COME A WHOLE NEW
CATEGORY.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY NOW
WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS INVENTING
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM, ECONOMIC
RACISM, CRIMINAL JUSTICE RACISM,
HEALTH CARE RACISM.
>> Tucker: YEP.
WARREN WAS PLEDGING TO FIGHT
HEALTH CARE RACISM.
AS DOCUMENTED BY DOCTORS?
SHE NEVER EXPLAINED.
OUR NURSES COMMITTING
HEALTH CARE RACISM?
WHO KNOWS.
SHE IT WAS THE LAST THING SHE
DID PRAY SHE KEPT GOING.
BY EARLY THIS YEAR, NUNES SAYING
WAS PROMISING TRANSGENDER
CHILDREN
PICKER CABINET MEMBERS, FOR
REAL.
>> I’M GOING TO HAVE A SECRETARY
OF EDUCATION THAT THIS YOUNG
TRANS PERSON INTERVIEWS ON MY
BEHALF, AND ONLY IF THIS PERSON
BELIEVES THAT OUR SECRETARY OR
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION NOMINEE
IS SOMEONE WHO IS COMMITTED TO
CREATING A WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT, A SAFE ENVIRONMENT,
AND A FULL EDUCATIONAL
CURRICULUM FOR EVERYONE, WELL,
THAT PERSON BE ADVANCED TO BE A
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION.
DO YOU LIKE THAT?
LET’S DO THAT.
>> Tucker: SO WAS THAT
PANDERING?
WITH THAT SCRIPTED?
NO.
IT WASN’T.
NO LOBBY GROUP TOLD HER TO SAY
THAT.
YOU COULDN’T MAKE THAT UP.
SHE CAME TO THAT ON HER OWN
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE MEANT IT.
AFTER A WHILE, THE WOKENESS
INFECTED HER BRAIN SO COMPLETELY
TOOK OVER ELIZABETH WARREN, THAT
SHE REALLY BELIEVED WHAT SHE WAS
SAYING.
GOT CRAZIER AND CRAZIER.
REPARATIONS FOR COUPLES?
GREAT IDEA FOR A GENDER BINARY
PEOPLE?
THE BACKBONE OF OUR DEMOCRACY,
SHE REALLY SAID THAT.
EVENTUALLY IT WAS TOO MUCH, EVEN
FOR LIBERALS.
THEY LOOK AT THIS AND SAID, WHAT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
BERNIE SANDERS, MEANWHILE, WAS
PROMISING UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
SOMETHING THEY ACTUALLY WANT.
WHETHER IT’S A GOOD IDEA OR NOT,
SOMETHING PEOPLE WANTED.
WARREN TRIED TO JUMP ON AND
PROMISE THE SAME THING EXCEPT
SHE SAID SHE WOULD MAGICALLY DO
IT WITHOUT RAISING TAXES ON THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
AGAIN, EVEN DEMOCRATS CANNOT BUY
IT AFTER A WHILE.
WHEN WARREN FINALLY GIVES UP
THIS CHARADE -- I AM RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT NATIONAL, YOU ARE NOT,
PLEASE -- WILL YOU BE ABLE TO